[Music]
well when I say visual novel I mean like
your normal visual novel that goes there
doesn't try to be anything it doesn't
try to be a phage day night or a Clannad
because the problem I had with it was
like it's just the way that it's like
gonna eat lunch you don't eat lunch and
it's like don't eat lunch and then like
the story Oh progress has oh you didn't
eat lunch you had sex instead like it's
like no ID lunch give you this sexual
testosterone to [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh Dave and
it's just the way that the decisions are
never clean cut to me they're always
like do skip class or do you not okay
you went to class
you've got [ __ ] [ __ ] and like it
just goes on for too long or don't think
about don't think alright we just we
just playing spoon aces yeah yeah well
actually a school a zoo be you want you
went to class
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't go to
class do you still mug to bishops the
one thing that I will save our school
days is it took it literally took the
expression just [ __ ] her to a whole new
expression hey it was like oh you're
interested in her well [ __ ] her no no he
took that to a completely different view
point as to literally fornicate her and
it's just the way that he literally
[ __ ] his problems like very literally
and he doesn't he actually they think
he's doing anything wrong
yeah it's just that he's so idiot like
it's like this is why I raged quit
because I love romance plot lines so
much and then this idiot is just like
ruin it was like it was like a bad hand
tie that had no hand tie aspects to it
if it had hentai aspects to it I
probably would have enjoyed it a lot I
had no idea what the hell was happening
oh my god but yeah that was our school
they ranked kids oh yes there will
probably be more school days is the
worst anime that I have ever watched in
my existence thus far and yeah that's
all you need to know
Oh get your [ __ ] together then I will
share with you guys my unethical passion
for my guilty pleasure that I've never
told anyone before [ __ ] good to it
school days because of your review that
I watched school days and liked it I
just have to say the world has engine
Mayan calendar was true you're watching
this from heaven or hell [ __ ] the
world's over Jean Jean Jean Jean Jean
[Applause]
Jean
I can't trash talk use you've
trash-talked yourself know why I liked
it but I watched the whole series
interesting hours I watched you in you
it was I went on just as calm but I went
on to some website [ __ ] did you I was
like visitor I was like a sorry for the
[ __ ] don't know like I am oh my god
oh you still feel like keeping your
Christmas tree up [ __ ] newsflash
let's just add to this insanity
I loved boku no pico that was [ __ ]
awesome
[Laughter]
like what the hell like how did you
expect him to react you saw his review
he hated it and and you have just
listened to the best moment of Pataki
ever